BAM what's happening you bad
[ __ ] uncle Joey Diaz December
29th two more days left in 2016 we
rocked 2016 2017 to suck my dick for
years I've been telling you guys Joey
steak and eggs you go how you waste your
time these [ __ ] heroes don't know how
to make steak and eggs they make a steak
then give me the toast then give us some
shitty potatoes then they give you two
eggs this is how you do it last night I
went to [ __ ] breakfast I went to a
birthday dinner with my wife I got a 12
ounce ribeye of Morton's I cut the thing
in half I ate six ounces with a salad
water and I had the [ __ ] appetizer
and that's it the other six ounces I
wait till the morning and what I do is I
put it on the grill I warm it up then I
slice it nice and thin I take two pieces
of weak toast I've lightly butter I put
them down and then a steak goes on top
of the toast you dumb [ __ ] so
the juice from the state goes into the
toast so when you put the egg yolk on
the toast you taste the meat you
understand me
take a look bad you see that you see
that you [ __ ] these anomalies that
steak and eggs right there so by the
time you push the [ __ ] steak walking
here you take this egg yolk you see that
you pick this [ __ ] up like this
like a savage that I am
you
BAM you take that angle you see that I
can't show you this [ __ ] you bite that
get a [ __ ] sandwich I'm not in high
school educating I'm an idiot I'm just a
fat [ __ ] who knows how to put flavors
together I'll be back with the joiner
today there's about 15 minutes for
dessert that's how you make steak and
eggs you dumb [ __ ] no potatoes I don't
even think either an egg white it's
nothing but yolk and meat directly to
your nutsack there's no
misunderstandings the rest of the day
the sperm is up the heart is up the
brain is clear
they [ __ ] stopping you you understand
me so [ __ ] you and your kale and steak
and eggs with an avocado like a [ __ ]
caveman have a good day